celebrities stop having plastic surgery
you don't look younger you don't look
better you just look weird when the
Beatles sank when I'm 64. they weren't
talking about having a face Mark
Madonna's Madonna doesn't look like a 64
year old woman because Madonna doesn't
look like a human being she looks like
what happens when you cross a lizard
with a lunchbox she's gone from being
one of the pop icons of her generation
to something you show your kids when you
want them to behave oh Darren you little
[__] if you don't come over and stop
behaving I'm going to get Madonna to
come around to your bedroom and take
away your PS5 look okay no one wants to
be 64 and no one wants to look 64.
everyone wants to look young enough to
sing the song Like a Virgin and for it
to look sexy but that isn't how life
works if I sung like a virgin in public
I'll be arrested and placed on the sex
offenders register if anything it's
going to get me arrested even quicker we
all age and that's absolutely fine
remember the song goes will you still
need me will you still Feed Me When I'm
64 not will you still need me will you
still feed me because I've had so much
plastic surgery I can't move my face
anymore